the Joe Rogan experience do you write
right do you like sit down write your
stand-up or do you just like have ideas
and work them out on stage a little bit
of both
yeah I'll write some and then just have
some some ideas
here's his my here's my kovat gameshow
idea is you get four people line them up
put masks on them and it's a it's a game
show called uh who said that because
everybody got masks on
you know who said that and then my other
one is a bad joke you got to get these
out your system before you hit
now the you knows everybody's wearing
masks the the bank robbers got a right
robber on his mask
you've been spent a lot of time alone
this is strange
you know you folks covetous is great
crazy what is this obsession with
becoming a game show host that's you
having your your special I've done it
yeah
don't do it is that obsession exists is
this kind of you know just the career
path yeah it happens anybody have been
offered a lot of game shows and I say
now yet they come with a large other
yeah they have been made it undeniable
for me on the game show side yet if I
was in the same position I was when I
took Fear Factor I'd take it again
because it changed my life changed my
life gave me freedom like real freedom
but its job there's a big difference
between doing that and doing stand-up
when you do stand-up you're having fun
when you're doing Fear Factor sometimes
you're having fun but it's a job you're
working it was a great job don't get me
wrong
yeah that's wonderful I think on the
gameshow side I really just got to put
my energy into who said that the Kovach
game show where steve harvey retires
from family feud that's an easy one I
would do family feud I wouldn't do
family
an easy one no it's an easy one survey
says yeah I remember back when Richard
Dawkins you in the airport and just
people asking you random [ __ ] good and
then they just you know we gotta drew
carey's got prices right that's an easy
one it looks easy I don't think it's
just I don't think it's for me I enjoy
some of them but just me and and what I
I think as a regular gig I got to be the
one creative about the said that Drew
Carey seems like he's asking money he's
stacking money like and no one even
knows about it I'll pat sajak oil
fortunes been on for hot my entire life
right but Pat Sajak's not a comic what
do you do before it will of fortune he
didn't do anything he was born on the
set he's been doing that forever he's
not a comic though maybe maybe he was at
one point in time maybe I don't think so
he's not a comic guy you ever heard of
Pat Sajak isn't a former weatherman in
talk-show host yeah that makes sense
yeah so he hit the jackpot but who else
what are the comics have done game shows
uh Howie Mandel Howie he's done a gang
of him right he had that one Deal or No
Deal
hid more than one right and he did I was
dealing note that was dealer know the
house naked uh something else uh Deal or
No Deal was a winner like why do they
ever stop that show I think they might
not live now I think they're so like
they were touring it I think I don't
know if it's I mean it might it would
move like CNBC instead of primetime TV
still being produced all the time like
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire still on
TV hmm
see I don't think I've quite sold you on
who said that so let's really dive into
the concept for people wearing masks
yeah somebody says something I was like
it if one of them was covet positive one
of them called it positive yeah why just
for the [ __ ] just for the mistake that
season uh three people get bored yeah
season 3 season three Hart Cove it but
and then once somebody says something
but it's not much movement
and nearly yes yes yeah you said that 30
second episodes you shoot 500 of them
it's on YouTube who said that was him
who said that was it Tim
how high did you get before you came
here no this is me CBD it's the kill
cliff CBD these are good right very
addictive good for you yeah I'm addicted
to these that actually is not a bad idea
for a show as long as they didn't like
you could gas and especially if it's
like they said things that were like
closely related to what they did like
maybe you can ask them what they did
like and then figure out who would say
what I think keeping it simple and quick
for these short attention spans Hey and
then maybe that's somebody that becomes
a legend on the show and they just kind
of if somebody and maybe it's gripped it
maybe it's real but if somebody's saying
who said that boom and they say whoa
that was fast
they're just miss episodes over intros
longer than episode intros 15-second
episode 4 seconds now let me know let me
know how other cells I'm gonna yeah take
it out I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take
it out on to you know to videoconference
in circuit just different do some
meetings
[Applause]